welcome back to Calgary countryside
making Patrick is a Calgary Stampede
favorite we caught up with her to talk
bad guys her milestone year and her love
of horses all right maybe you know I'm
here and trying to get the full Stampede
experience I don't have a lot of
experience on horses but you do a little
bit actually bought my first horse a
couple years ago she's still back in
Ontario so I miss her a lot so it's kind
of nice to be here again and makes me
miss her though what's your experience
here the Calgary Stampede well we played
last year and it was nuts
absolutely nuts somebody pulled the fire
alarm and it was it got really rowdy and
actually this is kind of cool though
while we got kicked off the stage well
the fire alarm was being dealt with and
the crowd actually just started singing
the song we got cut off singing and they
were just like chanting and chanting
until he came back out so there was a
lot of love it was really fun you love a
little bit of pandemonium I to make a
Patrick show yes I encourage it yes
Cheikh went well besides a wild Stampede
gig 2017 was also a wild year for Megan
at the C CMA Awards the country singer
took home female artist of the year the
Rising Star Award this year megan has
the second most C CMA Award nominations
with five including ones for album of
the year and a female artist of the year
last year and I really had no
expectations and in fact it totally blew
my mind I'm still not really over that
like I really truly did not expect that
so this year I mean you know having one
of the female artists and rising star
last year I mean that was so amazing I
would love for it to happen again you
know to get female artists in but I'm
trying not to put too much hope into
that or you know too much expectation
and just just keep doing what I'm doing
and not let that sort of dictate my my
focus you know
me
and I will be the beggar well the bad
guy is doing so well can you tell us the
story of that song how came about yeah I
mean you know it's it's like with any of
my songs you know it always comes a
little bit sometimes from my own
experience but this was something I was
talking with a friend of mine about we
were both kind of fresh out of
relationships and we both were the
people that had broken them off and you
know and we were just kind of talking
about the fact that it kind of doesn't
matter like what happened in the
relationship or what the reasons were
why you broke up if you're the one that
leaves you kind of always the bad guy in
to everybody else you know and and it's
almost like it's assumed that it was
just easier for you somehow because you
made the decision which is which is not
always the case it's it's a different
kind of hurt and it's a different kind
of pain and it's a different perspective
and so I just wanted to write something
that spoke to that perspective of a
breakup female artists are doing it's so
big in country right now you must be
getting a lot of messages on social
media a lot of people talking to you
like young girls that want to come up
and do it you're doing what's it like
talking to them it's amazing I mean when
I have I mean just in general when I
have fans reach out to me whether
they're trying to be in music or they're
doing that themselves or not you know
and I just have somebody reach out and
say this song changed my life or it's it
is everything right now and I felt like
you just reached inside of my brain and
took out what I was thinking and I
relate to it but when I have you know
young female artists that that look up
to me and you know want to do what I'm
doing I mean it's it's it's a really
cool feeling because I was that little
girl once you know and so when I get to
see that it's a really cool full circle
moment and it's also a good reminder for
me sometimes because I'm very hard on
myself you know it's a good reminder
that I'm further ahead than I think
sometimes you know so it's really cool